hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to classroom aquatic a
rather unique oculus rift game where you
are a dolphin in a classroom underwater
taking a pop quiz all right let's do
this that's really all I got to say I
got I got nothing else special you
literally are taking a pop quiz
hello teacher over there hello fellow
students am I one of you do I talks and
clicks and whistles beep ok class hope
you're all prepared we're all going to
have a little quiz oh no not hard at all
just mostly a review once we begin
you'll have 5 minutes to finish the test
uh holy crap and remember keep your eyes
to yourself you may begin the test now
okay in Marcel Proust's in the search of
lost time who did troph won Marie how
smart all these dolphins hate each one
doing nothing no no but teacher Wow look
at the pretty jellyfish oh-oh I got
three chances to cheat okay well what
question is that how much was it not get
read what's questions has two lines on
it oh I think looking at my actors not
cheating no no but what if it that one
no I don't know good good I don't know
oh wait that one oh okay I got it I got
it
okay sorry teach hey what's your oh
that's so interesting that you put that
is that that's quite an intriguing
answer teacher
hey good teacher would you look at it
yeah that's right keep on stepping
there was a way to throw erasers but I
don't remember how how do I know no no
no no no no no no the painting below
composition seven no no no doing
anything you can't prove nothing very
disturbing close to my face could you
step up a little bit sorry sorry teacher
no way God for that answer no I can move
ah son of a [ __ ] no no I want to win
please could I could I win guys is the
word I can't even read what they are
over there how am I supposed to be able
to cheat oh this is so unfair
it's unfair yeah yeah yeah yeah no no no
no yeah no no no no no no no no no no no
no no come why yeah yeah you oh good
Audrey okay that's deal are they all
deal is that what they all are okay what
was this one I I know that someone was
answering this one it also be no oh you
just switched no no that's alright
oh how much was it Oh God dingus damn it
okay got that one answered apparently I
got that one answered as well but I
don't know if that's good
why put D for all these they're all day
they're all day where is he okay now you
[ __ ] dingus damn it so hard it's so
hard
listen she said it so hard hello Lana
what's my time
oh my god I got less okay no sorry
don't stay dee dee alright you're gonna
turn way yeah yeah what happened oh no
what happened yeah no so weird to have
that happen okay
that one's I think this one would be me
Oh dee dee dee don't know anybody weird
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah I'm good I'm good teach
boy am i good I'm good oh yeah I got
this in the bag
[Music]
okay I obviously lost so uh-oh I'm over
here now
how long was I over there that was a
completely ridiculous game so that was
obviously one of the more strange oculus
rift games I've ever done I mean I was a
dolphin taking a pop quiz in a classroom
underwater and I accepted it fully I was
totally into it that's a really unique
aspect of the oculus rift I didn't think
anyone was actually going to do really
hard to but I a seven out of ten that's
good enough right that's good enough so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching if you want to play this for
yourself linked in the description also
playlist of other oculus rift games if
you want to see that leave a like if you
enjoyed this way
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye guys okay looks like it's
about time to get into the game as I
played myself man I gotta say this looks
really regal like incredibly real I
don't know if this next-generation or
something but now we know where the
title came from